The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So today, we're
going to close this
chapter, this short chapter,
on Bayesian inference.
Again, this was just
an overview of what you
can do in Bayesian inference.
And last time, we
started defining
what's called Jeffreys priors.
Right?
So when you do
Bayesian inference,
you have to introduce a
prior on your parameter.
And we said that
usually, it's something
that encodes your domain
knowledge about where
the parameter could be.
But there's also some
principle way to do it,
if you want to do Bayesian
inference without really
having to think about it.
And for example, one
of the natural priors
were those non-informative
priors, right?
If you were on a
compact set, it's
a uniform prior of this set.
If you're on an infinite set,
you can still think of taking
the [? 01s ?] prior.
And that's called an [INAUDIBLE]
That's always equal to 1.
And that's an improper prior
if you are an infinite set
or proportional to one.
And so another prior
that you can think of,
in the case where you have
a Fisher information, which
is well-defined, is something
called Jefferys prior.
And this prior is
a prior which is
proportional to square root of
the determinant of the Fisher
information matrix.
And if you're in
one dimension, it's
basically proportional to
a square root of the Fisher
information coefficient,
which we know, for example,
is the asymptotic variance
of the maximum likelihood
estimator.
And it turns out
that it's basically.
So square root of this
thing is basically
one over the standard deviation
of the maximum likelihood
estimator.
And so you can
compute this, right?
So you can compute for the
maximum likelihood estimator.
We know that the
variance is going
to be p1 minus p
in the Bernoulli
statistical experiment.
So you get this one over the
square root of this thing.
And for example, in
the Gaussian setting,
you actually have the
Fisher information,
even in the multi-variate
one, is actually
going to be something
like the identity matrix.
So this is proportional to 1.
It's the improper prior that
you get, in this case, OK?
Meaning that, for
the Gaussian setting,
no place where you
center your Gaussian
is actually better
than any other.
All right.
So we basically
left on this slide,
where we saw that
Jeffreys prior satisfy
a reparametrization
[INAUDIBLE] invariant
by transformation of
your parameter, which
is a desirable property.
And the way, it says that, well,
if I have my prior on theta,
and then I suddenly
decide that theta is not
the parameter I want to use
to parameterize my problem,
actually what I want
is phi of theta.
So think, for example, as theta
being the mean of a Gaussian,
and phi of theta as
being mean to the cube.
OK?
This is a one-to-one
map phi, right?
So for example, if I want to
go from theta to theta cubed,
and now I decide that this is
the actual parameter that I
want, well, then it means
that, on this parameter,
my original prior is going
to induce another prior.
And here, it says,
well, this prior
is actually also Jeffreys prior.
OK?
So it's essentially
telling you that,
for this new parametrization,
if you take Jeffreys prior, then
you actually go back to having
exactly something that's
of the form's [INAUDIBLE]
of determinant of the Fisher
information, but this
thing with respect
to your new
parametrization All right.
And so why is this true?
Well, it's just this
change of variable theorem.
So it's essentially telling
you that, if you call--
let's call p-- well, let's go
pi tilde of eta prior over eta.
And you have pi of
theta as the prior
over theta, than since eta
is of the form phi of theta,
just by change of variable,
so that's essentially
a probability result. It
says that pi tilde of eta
is equal to pi of eta
times d pi of theta times d
theta over d eta and--
sorry, is that the one?
Sorry, I'm going to
have to write it,
because I always forget this.
So if I take a function--
OK.
So what I want is to check.
OK, so I want the function
of eta that I can here.
And what I know is that
this is h of phi of theta.
All right?
So sorry, eta is
phi of theta, right?
Yeah.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to do the change of variable,
theta is phi inverse of eta.
So eta is phi of
theta, which means
that d eta is equal to d--
well, to phi prime
of theta d theta.
So when I'm going to write this,
I'm going to get integral of h.
Actually, let me
write this, as I
am more comfortable
writing this as e
with respect to eta of h of eta.
OK?
So that's just eta according
to being drawn from the prior.
And I want to write this as
the integral of he of eta times
some function, right?
So this is the
integral of h of phi
of theta pi of theta d theta.
Now, I'm going to do
my change of variable.
So this is going to be
the integral of h of eta.
And then pi of phi of--
so theta is phi inverse of eta.
And then d theta is phi
prime of theta d theta, OK?
And so what is pi of phi theta?
So this thing is proportional.
So we're in, say,
dimension 1, so it's
proportional of square root
of the Fisher information.
And the Fisher
information, we know,
is the expectation of the square
of the derivative of the log
likelihood, right?
So this is square root
of the expectation
of d over d theta of log of--
well, now, I need the density.
Well, let's just
call it l of theta.
And I want this to be taken
at phi inverse of eta squared.
And then what I pick up is the--
so I'm going to put
everything under the square.
So I get phi prime of
theta squared d theta.
OK?
So now, I have the
expectation of a square.
This does not depend, so this
is-- sorry, this is l of theta.
This is the expectation of
l of theta of an x, right?
That's for some variable,
and the expectation here
is with respect to x.
That's just the definition
of the Fisher information.
So now I'm going to squeeze
this guy into the expectation.
It does not depend on x.
It just acts as a constant.
And so what I have now
is that this is actually
proportional to
the integral of h
eta times the square root of
the expectation with respect
to x of what?
Well, here, I have d over
d theta of log of theta.
And here, this guy is really
d eta over d theta, right?
Agree?
So now, what I'm really left
by-- so I get d over d theta
times d--
sorry, times d theta over d eta.
so that's just d over
d eta of log of eta x.
And then this guy is now
becoming d eta, right?
OK, so this was a mess.
This is a complete mess, because
I actually want to use phi.
I should not actually
introduce phi at all.
I should just talk about d eta
over d theta type of things.
And then that would actually
make my life so much easier.
OK.
I'm not going to spend
more time on this.
This is really just
the idea, right?
You have square root
of a square in there.
And then, when you do
your change of variable,
you just pick up a square.
You just pick up
something in here.
And so you just move
this thing in there.
You get a square.
It goes inside the square.
And so your derivative
of the log likelihood
with respect to theta becomes
a derivative of the log
likelihood with respect to eta.
And that's the only thing
that's happening here.
I'm just being super
sloppy, for some reason.
OK.
And then, of course, now,
what you're left with
is that this is really
just proportional.
Well, this is actually equal.
Everything is
proportional, but this
is equal to the Fisher
information tilde with respect
to eta now.
Right?
You're doing this
with respect to eta.
And so that's your new
prior with respect to eta.
OK.
So one thing that
you want to do,
once you have-- so
remember, when you actually
compute your
posterior rate, rather
than having-- so you
start with a prior,
and you have some observations,
let's say, x1 to xn.
When you do Bayesian
inference, rather than spitting
out just some theta hat, which
is an estimator for theta,
you actually spit out an
entire posterior distribution--
pi of theta, given x1 xn.
OK?
So there's an
entire distribution
on the [INAUDIBLE] theta.
And you can actually use this
to perform inference, rather
than just having one number.
OK?
And so you could actually
build confidence regions
from this thing.
OK.
And so a Bayesian
confidence interval--
so if your set of parameters
is included in the real line,
then you can actually--
it's not even guaranteed
to be to be an interval.
So let me call it a confidence
region, so a Bayesian
confidence region, OK?
So it's just a random subspace.
So let's call it r,
is included in theta.
And when you have the
deterministic one,
we had a definition, which was
with respect to the randomness
of the data, right?
That's how you actually
had a random subset.
So you had a random
confidence interval.
Here, it's actually
conditioned on the data,
but with respect
to the randomness
that you actually get from
your posterior distribution.
OK?
So such that the
probability that your theta
belongs to this
confidence region,
given x1 xn is, say,
at least 1 minus alpha.
Let's just take it
equal to 1 minus alpha.
OK so that's a confidence
region at level 1 minus alpha.
OK, so that's one way.
So why would you actually--
when I actually implement
Bayesian inference,
I'm actually spitting out
that entire distribution.
I need to summarize this thing
to communicate it, right?
I cannot just say this
is this entire function.
I want to know where
are the regions
of high probability, where my
perimeter is supposed to be?
And so here, when I have
this thing, what I actually
want to have is
something that says,
well, I want to
summarize this thing
into some subset of the
real line, in which I'm
sure that the area under the
curve, here, of my posterior
is actually 1 minus alpha.
And there's many ways
to do this, right?
So one way to do this is
to look at level sets.
And so rather than
actually-- so let's
say my posterior
looks like this.
I know, for example, if I
have a Gaussian distribution,
I can actually take my posterior
to be-- my posterior is
actually going to be Gaussian.
And what I can do is to try
to cut it here on the y-axis
so that now, the area under
the curve, when I cut here,
is actually 1 minus alpha.
OK, so I have some
threshold tau.
If tau goes to plus
infinity, then I'm
going to have that this
area under the curve
here is going to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well, no.
So the area under
the curve, when
tau is going to
plus infinity, think
of the small, the when
tau is just right here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So this is
actually going to 0, right?
And so I start here.
And then I start going down
and down and down and down,
until I actually get something
which is going down to 1 plus
alpha.
And if tau is going down to 0,
then my area under the curve
is going to--
if tau is here, I'm
cutting nowhere.
And so I'm getting 1, right?
Agree?
Think of, when tau
is very close to 0,
I'm cutting [? s ?]
s very far here.
And so I'm getting some
area under the curve,
which is almost everything.
And so it's going to 1--
as tau going down to 0.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this only
work for [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
No, it does not.
I mean-- so this is a picture.
So those two things work
for all of them, right?
But when you have a
[? bimodal, ?] actually,
this is actually
when things start
to become interesting, right?
So when we built a frequentist
confidence interval,
it was always of the form x
bar plus or minus something.
But now, if I start to
have a posterior that
looks like this, what I'm
going to start cutting off,
I'm going to have two--
I mean, my confidence
region is going
to be the union of
those two things, right?
And it really reflects
the fact that there
is this bimodal thing.
It's going to say,
well, with hyperbole,
I'm actually going to
be either here or here.
Now, the meaning here of a
Bayesian confidence region
and the confidence interval are
completely distinct notions,
right?
And I'm going to work
out on example with you
so that we can actually
see that sometimes--
I mean, both of
them, actually you
can come up with
some crazy paradoxes.
So since we don't
have that much time,
I will actually talk to you
about why, in some instances,
it's actually a good idea to
think of Bayesian confidence
intervals rather than
frequentist ones.
So before we go into
more details about what
those Bayesian
confidence intervals are,
let's remind
ourselves what does it
mean to have a frequentist
confidence interval?
Right?
OK.
So when I have a frequentist
confidence interval,
let's say something like x bar n
to minus 1.96 sigma over root n
and x bar n plus 1.96
sigma over root n,
so that's the
confidence interval
that you get for the
mean of some Gaussian
with known variants to be
equal to sigma square, OK.
So what we know is that
the meaning of this
is the probability
that theta belongs
to this is equal to 95%, right?
And this, more
generally, you can
think of being q alpha over 2.
And what you're going to get
is 1 minus alpha here, OK?
So what does it mean here?
Well, it looks very much
like what we have here,
except that we're not
conditioning on x1 xn.
And we should not.
Because there was a question
like that in the midterm--
if I condition on x1 xn, this
probability is either 0 or 1.
OK?
Because once I
condition-- so here,
this probability, actually,
here is with respect
to the randomness in x1 xn.
So if I condition--
so let's build this thing,
r freq, for frequentist.
Well, given x1 xn--
and actually, I don't
need to know x1 xn really.
What I need to know
is what xn bar is.
Well, this thing now is what?
It's 1, if theta is
in r, and it's 0,
if theta is not in r, right?
That's all there is.
This is a deterministic
confidence interval,
once I condition x1 xn.
So I have a number.
The average is maybe 3.
And so I get 3.
Either theta is between 3
minus 0.5 or in 3 plus 0.5,
or it's not.
And so there's basically--
I mean, I write
it as probability,
but it's really not a
probalistic statement.
It's either it's true or not.
Agreed?
So what does it mean to have
a frequentist confidence
interval?
It means that if I were--
and here, where the word
frequentist comes from,
it says that if I repeat this
experiment over and over,
meaning that on Monday, I
collect a sample of size n,
and I build a
confidence interval,
and then on Tuesday, I collect
another sample of size n,
and I build a
confidence interval,
and on Wednesday, I do this
again and again, what's going
to happen is the following.
I'm going to have my true
theta that lives here.
And then on Monday, this
is the confidence interval
that I build.
OK, so this is the real line.
The true theta is here, and
this is the confidence interval
I build on Monday.
All right?
So x bar was here, and this
is my confidence interval.
On Tuesday, I build this
confidence interval maybe.
x bar was closer to
theta, but smaller.
But then on Wednesday, I build
this confidence interval.
I'm not here.
It's not in there.
And that's this case.
Right?
It happens that it's
just not in there.
And then on Thursday,
I build another one.
I almost miss it, but
I'm in there, et cetera.
Maybe here, Here, I miss again.
And so what it means to have a
confidence interval-- so what
does it mean to have a
confidence interval at 95%?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, so
it means that if I repeat this
the frequency of times--
hence, the word
frequentist-- at which
I'm actually going
to overlap that,
I'm actually going to
contain theta, should be 95%.
That's what frequentist means.
So it's just a matter
of trusting that.
So on one given thing, one
given realization of your data,
it's not telling you anything.
[INAUDIBLE] it's there or not.
So it's not really
something that's actually
something that assesses the
confidence of your decision,
such as data is in there or not.
It's something that
assesses the confidence
you have in the method
that you're using.
If you were you repeat
it over and again,
it'd be the same thing.
It would be 95% of the
time correct, right?
So for example, we know
that we could build a test.
So it's pretty clear
that you can actually
build a test for whether
theta is equal to theta naught
or not equal to
theta naught, by just
checking whether theta naught
is in a confidence interval
or not.
And what it means is
that, if you actually
are doing those tests at 5%,
that means that 5% of the time,
if you do this over and
again, 5% of the time
you're going to be wrong.
I mentioned my wife
does market research.
And she does maybe, I don't
know, 100,000 tests a year.
And if they do
all of them at 1%,
then it means that 1% of the
time, which is a lot of time,
right?
When you do 100,000 a
year, it's 1,000 of them
are actually wrong.
OK, I mean, she's
actually hedging
against the fact that 1% of
them that are going to be wrong.
That's 1,000 of them that
are going to be wrong.
Just like, if you do this
100,000 times at 95%,
5,000 of those guys
are actually not going
to be the correct ones.
OK?
So I mean, it's kind of scary.
But that's the way it is.
So that's with the frequentist
interpretation of this is.
Now, as I mentioned, when we
started this Bayesian chapter,
I said, Bayesian
statistics converge to--
I mean, Bayesian decisions
and Bayesian methods converge
to frequentist methods.
When the sample size
is large enough,
they lead to the same decisions.
And in general, they
need not be the same,
but they tend to
actually, when the sample
size is large enough, to
have the same behavior.
Think about, for
example, the posterior
that you have when you have
in the Gaussian case, right?
We said that, in
the Gaussian case,
what you're going
to see is that it's
as if you had an extra
observation which
was essentially
given by your prior.
OK?
And now, what's going to happen
is that, when this just one
observation among n
plus 1, it's really
going to be totally
drawn, and you
won't see it when the
sample size grows larger.
So Bayesian methods are
particularly useful when
you have a small sample size.
And when you have a small sample
size, the effect of the prior
is going to be bigger.
But most importantly,
you're not going
to have to repeat this
thing over and again.
And you're going
to have a meaning.
You're going to have
to have something
that has a meaning for
this particular data set
that you have.
When I said that the probability
that theta belongs to r--
and here, I'm going to specify
the fact that it's a Bayesian
confidence region,
like this one--
this is actually
conditionally on the data
that you've collected.
It says, given this data, given
the points that you have--
just put in some numbers,
if you want, in there--
it's actually telling
you the probability
that theta belongs to
this Bayesian thing,
to this Bayesian
confidence region.
Here, since I have
conditioned on x1 xn,
this probability is really
just with respect to theta
drawn from the prior, right?
And so now, it has a
slightly different meaning.
It's just telling
you that when--
it's really making a
statement about where
the regions of hyperability
of your posterior are.
Now, why is that useful?
Well, there's actually
an interesting story that
goes behind Bayesian methods.
Anybody knows the story of
the USS I think it's Scorpion?
Do you know the story?
So that was an American
vessel that disappeared.
I think it was close to
Bermuda or something.
But you can tell the story
of the Malaysian Airlines,
except that I don't think
it's such a successful story.
But the idea was
essentially, we're
trying to find where
this thing happened.
And of course, this
is a one-time thing.
You need something
that works once.
You need something that works
for this particular vessel.
And you don't care, if you go
to the Navy, and you tell them,
well, here's a method.
And for 95 out of 100 vessels
that you're going to lose,
we're going to be
able to find it.
And they want this to work
for this particular one.
And so they were
looking, and they were
diving in different places.
And suddenly, they
brought in this guy.
I forget his name.
I mean, there's a whole story
about this on Wikipedia.
And he started
collecting the data
that they had from different
dives and maybe from currents.
And he started to
put everything in.
And he said, OK, what is
the posterior distribution
of the location of the
vessel, given all the things
that I've seen?
And what have you seen?
Well, you've seen that it's
not here, it's not there,
and it's not there.
And you've also seen that the
currents were going that way,
and the winds were
going that way.
And you can actually
put some modeling traits
to understand this.
Now, given this, for this
particular data that you have,
you can actually think of having
a two-dimensional density that
tells you where it's more
likely that the vessel is.
And where are you going
to be looking for?
Well, if it's a
multimodal distribution,
you're just going to go
to the highest mode first,
because that's where it's
the most likely to be.
And maybe it's not
there, so you're just
going to update your
posterior, based on the fact
that it's not there,
and do it again.
And actually, after
two dives, I think,
he actually found the thing.
And that's exactly where
Bayesian statistics
start to kick in.
Because you put a lot of
knowledge into your model,
but you also can actually factor
in a bunch of information,
right?
The model, he had
to build a model
that was actually taking into
account and currents, and when.
And what you can have
as a guarantee is that,
when you talk about
the probability
that this vessel is
in this location,
given what you've
observed in the past,
it actually has some sense.
Whereas, if you were to
use a frequentist approach,
then there's no probability.
Either it's underneath this
position or it's not, right?
So that's actually where
it start to make sense.
And so you can
actually build this.
And there's actually
a lot of methods
that are based on,
for search, that
are based on Bayesian methods.
I think, for example,
the Higgs boson
was based on a lot
of Bayesian methods,
because this is something
you need to find [INAUDIBLE],,
right?
I mean, there was a lot of
prior that has to be built in.
OK.
So now, you build this
confidence interval.
And the nicest way to do
it is to use level sets.
But again, just like for
Gaussians, I mean, if I had,
even in the Gaussian
case, I decided
to go at x bar plus
or minus something,
but I could go at something
that's completely asymmetric.
So what's happening is
that here, this method
guarantees that you're
going to have the narrowest
possible confidence intervals.
That's essentially what
it's telling you, OK?
Because every time I'm choosing
a point, starting from here,
I'm actually putting as much
area under the curve as I can.
All right.
So those are called Bayesian
confidence [? interval. ?]
Oh yeah, and I
promised you that we're
going to work on some
example that actually
gives a meaning to what I just
told you, with actual numbers.
So this is something that's
taken from Wasserman's book.
And also, it's
coming from a paper,
from a stats paper,
from [? Wolpert ?] and I
don't know who, from the '80s.
And essentially,
this is how it works.
So assume that you have
n equals 2 observations.
And you have y1, so those
observations are y1--
no, sorry, let's
call them x1, which
is theta, plus epsilon 1 and x2,
which is theta plus epsilon 2,
where epsilon 1 and
epsilon 2 are iid.
And the probability
that epsilon i is equal
to plus 1 is equal
to the probability
that epsilon i is equal to
minus 1 is equal to 1/2.
OK, so it's just the uniform
sign plus minus 1, OK?
Now, let's think
about so you're trying
to do some inference on theta.
Maybe you actually want to
find some inference on theta
that's actually based on--
and that's based only
on the x1 and x2.
OK?
So I'm going to actually
build a confidence interval.
But what I really
want to build is a--
but let's start
thinking about how
I would find an estimator
for those two things.
Well, what values am I
going to be getting, right?
So I'm going to get either
theta plus 1 or theta minus 1.
And actually, I can
get basically four
different observations, right?
Sorry, four different
pairs of observations--
plus plus theta minus 1.
Agreed?
Those are the four possible
observations that I can get.
Agreed?
Either they're both equal to
plus 1, both equal to minus 1,
or one of the two
is equal to plus
1, the other one to
minus 1, or the epsilons.
OK.
So those are the four
observations I can get.
So in particular, if
they take the same value,
and you know it's either
theta plus 1 or theta minus 1,
and if they take a different
value, I know one of them
is theta plus 1, and one
is actually theta minus 1.
So in particular, if I take the
average of those two guys, when
they take different
values, I know I'm actually
getting theta right.
So let's build a
confidence region.
OK, so I'm actually going to
take a confidence region, which
is just a singleton.
And I'm going to
say the following.
Well, if x1 is equal to x2, I'm
just going to take x1 minus 1,
OK?
So I'm just saying,
well, I'm never
going to able to resolve
whether it's plus 1 or minus 1
that actually gives
me the best one,
so I'm just going to take
a dive and say, well, it's
just plus 1.
OK?
And then, if they're
different, then here,
I can do much better.
I'm going to actually
just think the average.
OK?
Now, what I claim is that
this is a confidence region--
and by default, when
I don't mention it,
this is a frequentist
confidence region--
at level 75%.
OK?
So let's just check that.
To check that this
is correct, I need
to check that the probability
under the realization of x1
and x2, that theta belongs,
is one of those two guys,
is actually equal to 0.75.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What are
the [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well, it's
just the frequentist confidence
interval that does not
need to be an interval.
Actually, in this case, it's
going to be an interval.
But that's just what it means.
Yeah, region for Bayesian
was just because--
I mean, the
confidence intervals,
when we're frequentist,
we tend to make them
intervals, because we want--
but when you're Bayesian, and
you're doing this level set
thing, you cannot
really guarantee,
unless its [INAUDIBLE] is
going to be an interval.
So region is just a way to
not have to say interval,
in case it's not.
OK.
So I have this thing.
So what I need to check is
the probability that theta
is in one of those
two things, right?
So what I need to find is
the probability that theta
is an [INAUDIBLE] Well, x1 minus
1 and x1 is not equal to x2.
And those are disjoint events,
so it's plus the probability
that theta is in x1
plus x2 over 2 and x1--
sorry, that's equal.
That's different.
OK.
And OK, just before we actually
finish the computation,
why do I have 75%?
75% is 3/4.
So it means that
we have four cases.
And essentially, I did
not account for one case.
And it's true.
I did not account
for this case, when
the both of the epsilon
i's are equal to minus 1.
Right?
So this is essentially
the one I'm not going
to be able to account for.
And so we'll see
that in a second.
So in this case, we know
that everything goes great.
Right?
So in this case, this is--
OK.
Well, let's just start
from the first line.
So the first line
is the probability
that theta is equal to x1 minus
1 and those two are equal.
So this is the probability
that theta is equal to--
well, this is theta
plus epsilon 1 minus 1.
And epsilon 1 is equal
to epsilon 2, right?
Because I can remove
the theta from here,
and I can actually remove
so that this guy here is
just epsilon 1 is equal to 1.
So when I intersect
with this guy,
it's actually the same thing
as epsilon 1 is equal to 1,
as well--
episilon 2 is equal
to 1, as well, OK?
So this first thing is actually
equal to the probability
that epsilon 1 is equal to 1
and epsilon 2 is equal to 1,
which is equal to what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, 1/4, right?
So that's just the
first case over there.
They're independent.
Now, I still need to
do the second one.
So this case is what?
Well, when those things are
equal, x1 plus x2 over 2
is what?
Well, I get theta
plus theta over 2.
So that's just equal
to the probability
that epsilon 1 plus epsilon
2 over 2 is equal to 0
and epsilon 1 is
different from epsilon 2.
Agreed?
I just removed the thetas from
these equations, because I can.
They're just on both
sides every time.
OK.
And so that means what?
That means that the second
part-- so this thing
is actually equal to
1/4 plus the probability
that epsilon 1 and epsilon
2 over 2 is equal to 0.
I can remove the 2.
So this is just the
probability that one is 1,
and the other one
is minus 1, right?
So that's equal
to the probability
that epsilon 1 is equal to 1 and
epsilon 2 is equal to minus 1
plus the probability that
epsilon 1 is equal to minus 1
and epsilon 2 is
equal to plus 1, OK?
Because they're disjoint events.
So I can break them
into the sum of the two.
And each of those guys is also
one of the atomic part of it.
It's one of the basic things.
And so each of those
guys has probability 1/4.
And so here, we can really
see that we accounted
for everything, except for the
case when epsilon 1 was equal
to minus 1, and epsilon
2 was equal to minus 1.
So this is 1/4.
This is 1/4.
So the whole thing
is equal to 3/4.
So now, what we have is that
the probability that epsilon 1
is in--
so the probability that data
belongs to this confidence
region is equal to 3/4.
And that's very nice.
But the thing is some
people are sort of--
I mean, it's not super nice
to be able to see this,
because, in a way, I know that,
if I observe x1 and x2 that
are different, I know
for sure that theta,
that I actually got
the right theta, right?
That this confidence
interval is actually
happening with probability 1.
And the problem is
that I do not know--
I cannot make this precise
with the notion of frequentist
confidence intervals.
OK?
Because frequentist
confidence intervals
have to account for the
fact that, in the future,
it might not be the case
that x1 and x2 are different.
So Bayesian confidence
regions, by definition--
well, they're all gone--
but they are conditioned
on the data that I have.
And so that's what I want.
I want to be able to make
this statement conditionally
and the data that I have.
OK.
So if I want to be able
to make this statement,
if I want to build a
Bayesian confidence region,
I'm going to have to
put a prior on theta.
So without loss of generality--
I mean, maybe with--
but let's assume
that pi is a prior on theta.
And let's assume that pi
of j is strictly positive
for all integers
j equal, say, 0--
well, actually, for all j in the
integers, positive or negative.
OK.
So that's a pretty weak
assumption on my prior.
I'm just assuming that
theta is some integer.
And now, let's build our
Bayesian confidence region.
Well, if I want to build a
Bayesian confidence region,
I need to understand what
my posterior is going to be.
OK?
And if I want to understand what
my posterior is going to be,
I actually need to build
a likelihood, right?
So we know that it's the
product of the likelihood
and of the prior divided by--
OK.
So what is my likelihood?
So my likelihood
is the probability
of x1 x2, given theta.
Right?
That's what the
likelihood should be.
And now let's say
that actually, just
to make things a
little simpler, let
us assume that x1 is
equal to, I don't know, 5,
and x2 is equal to 7.
OK?
So I'm not going to take the
case where they're actually
equal to each other, because
I know that, in this case,
x1 and x2 are different.
I know I'm going to actually
nail exactly what theta is,
by looking at the average
of those guys, right?
Here, it must be that
theta is equal to 6.
So what I want is to compute
the likelihood at 5 and 7, OK?
And what is this likelihood?
Well, if theta is
equal to 6, that's
just the probability that I
will observe 5 and 7, right?
So what is the probability
I observe 5 and 7?
Yeah?
1?
AUDIENCE: 1/4.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's 1/4, right?
As the probability, I have
minus 1 for the first epsilon 1,
right?
So this is infinity 6.
This is the probability that
epsilon 1 is equal to minus 1,
and epsilon 2 is equal to
plus 1, which is equal to 1/4.
So this probability is 1/4.
If theta is different from
6, what is this probability?
So if theta is different
from 6, since we
know that we've only
loaded the integers--
so if theta has to
be another integer,
what is the probability
that I see 5 and 7?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 0.
So that's my likelihood.
And if I want to know
what my posterior is,
well, it's just
pi of theta times
p of 5/6, given theta, divided
by the sum over all T's, say,
in Z. Right?
So now, I just need to
normalize this thing.
So of pi of T, p of
4/6, given T. Agreed?
That's just the definition
of the posterior.
But when I sum
these guys, there's
only one that counts,
because, for those things,
we know that this is actually
equal to 0 for every T,
except for when T is equal to 6.
So this entire sum
here is actually
equal to pi of 6
times p of 5/6--
sorry, 5/7, of 5/7,
given that theta
is equal to 6, which we
know is equal to 1/4.
And I did not tell
you what pi of 6 was.
But it's the same thing here.
The posterior for any
theta that's not 6
is actually going to be-- this
guy's going to be equal to 0.
So I really don't
care what this guy is.
So what it means is that
my posterior becomes what?
It becomes the
posterior pi of theta,
given 5 and 7 is equal to--
well, when theta is not
equal to 6, this is actually 0.
So regardless of what I do here,
I get something which is 0.
And if theta is equal
to 6, what I get
is pi of 6 times
p of 5/7, given 6,
which I've just computed
here, which is 1/4 divided
by pi of 6 times 1/4.
So it's the ratio of two
things that are identical.
So I get 1.
So now, my posterior
tells me that, given
that I observe 5
and 7, theta has
to be 1 with probability-- has
to be 6 with probability 1.
So now, I say that this
thing here-- so now, this
is not something
that actually makes
sense when I talk about
frequentist confidence
intervals.
They don't really make sense,
to talk about confidence
intervals, given something.
And so now, given that
I observe 5 and 7,
I know that the probability
of theta is equal to 1.
And in this sense, the
Bayesian confidence interval
is actually more meaningful.
So one thing I want to actually
say about this Bayesian
confidence interval
is that it's--
I mean, here, it's equal
to the value 1, right?
So it really encompasses
the thing that we want.
But the fact that
we actually computed
it using the Bayesian
posterior and the Bayesian rule
did not really matter
for this argument.
All I just said was
that it had a prior.
But just what I
want to illustrate
is the fact that we can
actually give a meaning
to the probability that
theta is equal to 6,
given that I see 5 and 7.
Whereas, we cannot really
in the other cases.
And we don't have
to be particularly
precise in the prior and theta
to be able to give theta this--
to give this meaning.
OK?
All right.
So now, as I said, I think
the main power of Bayesian
inference is that it spits out
the posterior distribution,
and not just the single
number, like frequentists
would give you.
Then we can say decorate, or
theta hat, or point estimate,
with maybe some
confidence interval.
Maybe we can do
a bunch of tests.
But at the end of the
day, we just have,
essentially, one number, right?
Then maybe we can
understand where
the fluctuations of this number
are in a frequentist setup.
but the Bayesian
framework is essentially
giving you a natural method.
And you can interpret it in
terms of the probabilities that
are associated to the prior.
But you can actually
also try to make some--
so a Bayesian, if you
give me any prior,
you're going to actually build
an estimator from this prior,
maybe from the posterior.
And maybe it's going to have
some frequentist properties.
And that's what's really nice
about [? Bayesians, ?] is
that you can
actually try to give
some frequentist properties
of Bayesian methods, that
are built using
Bayesian methodology.
But you cannot really
go the other way around.
If I give you a
frequency methodology,
how are you going to say
something about the fact
that there's a prior
going on, et cetera?
And so this is actually
one of the things
there's actually some research
that's going on for this.
They call it Bayesian
posterior concentration.
And one of the things--
so there's something
called the Bernstein-von
Mises theorem.
And those are a
class of theorems,
and those are essentially
methods that tell you, well,
if I actually run
a Bayesian method,
and I look at the
posterior that I get--
it's going to be
something like this--
but now, I try to study this
in a frequentist point of view,
there's actually a
true parameter of theta
somewhere, the true one.
There's no prior for this guy.
This is just one fixed number.
Is it true that as
my sample size is
going to go to infinity,
then this thing is going
to concentrate around theta?
And the rate of
concentration of this thing,
the size of this width,
the standard deviation
of this thing, is something
that should decay maybe
like 1 over square root of
n, or something like this.
And the rate of
posterior concentration,
when you characterize it, it's
called the Bernstein-von Mises
theorem.
And so people are
looking at this
in some non-parametric cases.
You can do it in
pretty much everything
we've been doing before.
You can do it for non-parametric
regression estimation
or density estimation.
You can do it for,
of course-- you
can do it for sparse
estimation, if you want.
OK.
So you can actually
compute the procedure and--
yeah.
And so you can think of it as
being just a method somehow.
Now, the estimator
I'm talking about-- so
that's just a general Bayesian
posterior concentration.
But you can also
try to understand
what is the property
of something that's
extracted from this posterior.
And one thing that
we actually describe
was, for example,
well, given this guy,
maybe it's a good idea
to think about what
the mean of this
thing is, right?
So there's going to
be some theta hat,
which is just the integral of
theta pi theta, given x1 xn--
so that's my posterior--
d theta.
Right?
So that's the posterior mean.
That's the expected
value with respect
to the posterior distribution.
And I want to know how
does this thing behave,
how close it is to a
true theta if I actually
am in a frequency setup.
So that's the posterior mean.
But this is not the only thing
I can actually spit out, right?
This is definitely
uniquely defined.
If you give me a
distribution, I can actually
spit out its posterior mean.
But I can also think of
the posterior median.
But now, if this
is not continuous,
you might have some uncertainty.
Maybe the median is
not uniquely defined,
and so maybe that's not
something you use as much.
Maybe you can actually talk
about the posterior mode.
All right, so for example, if
you're posterior density looks
like this, then
maybe you just want
to summarize your
posterior with this number.
So clearly, in this case,
it's not such a good idea,
because you completely
forget about this mode.
But maybe that's
what you want to do.
Maybe you want to focus
on the most peak mode.
And this is actually called
maximum a posteriori.
As I said, maybe
you want a sample
from this posterior
distribution.
OK, and so in all these cases,
these Bayesian estimators
will depend on the
prior distribution.
And the hope is that, as
the sample size grows,
you won't see that again.
OK.
So to conclude, let's just
do a couple of experiments.
So if I look at--
did we do this?
Yes.
So for example, so let's
focus on the posterior mean.
And we know-- so remember
in experiment one--
[INAUDIBLE] example
one, what we had
was x1 xn that were
[? iid, ?] Bernoulli p,
and the prior I put on p was
a beta with parameter aa.
OK?
And if I go back to
what we computed,
you can actually compute
the posterior of this thing.
And we know that it's
actually going to be--
sorry, that was uniform?
Where is-- yeah.
So what we get is that
the posterior, this thing
is actually going to be
a beta with parameter
a plus the sum, so a
plus the number of 1s
and a plus the number of 0s.
OK?
And the beta was just
something that looked like--
the density was p to the
a minus 1, 1 minus p.
OK?
So if I want to understand
the posterior mean,
I need to be able to compute
the expectation of a beta,
and then maybe plug
in a for a plus
this guy and minus this guy.
OK.
So actually, let me do this.
So what is the expectation?
So what I want is
something that looks
like the integral between 0
and 1 of p times a minus 1--
sorry, p times p a minus
1, 1 minus p, b minus 1.
Do we agree that this--
and then there's a
normalizing constant.
Let's call it c.
OK?
So this is what I
need to compute.
So that's c of a and b.
Do we agree that
this is the posterior
mean with respect to a beta
with parameters a and b?
Right?
I just integrate p
against the density.
So what does this
thing look like?
Well, I can actually
move this guy in here.
And here, I'm going to
have a plus 1 minus 1.
OK?
So the problem is that
this thing is actually--
the constant is going to
play a big role, right?
Because this is
essentially equal
to c a plus 1b
divided by c ab, where
ca plus 1b is just
the normalizing
constant of a beta a plus 1 b.
So I need to know the ratio
of those two constants.
And this is not something--
I mean, this is just
a calculus exercise.
So in this case,
what you get is--
sorry.
In this case, you get--
well, OK, so we get
essentially a divided by,
I think, it's a plus b.
Yeah, it's a plus b.
So that's this quantity.
OK?
And when I plug in a to be this
guy and b to be this guy, what
I get is a plus sum of the xi.
And then I get a plus this
guy, a plus n minus this guy.
So those two guys
go away, and I'm
left with 2a plus n,
which does not work.
No, that actually works.
And so now what I do, I
can actually divide and get
this thing, over there.
OK.
So what you can see, the reason
why this thing has been divided
is that you can really see
that, as n goes to infinity,
then this thing behaves
like xn bar, which
is our frequentist estimator.
The effect of a is
actually going away.
The effect of the prior, which
is completely captured by a,
is going away as n
goes to infinity.
Is there any question?
You guys have a question.
What is it?
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, on the
board, is that divided
by some [INAUDIBLE] stuff?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Is
that divided by what?
AUDIENCE: That a over a plus
b, and then you just expanded--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Oh yeah, yeah,
then I said that this
is equal to this, right.
So that's for a becomes a plus
sum of the xi's, and b becomes
a plus n minus sum of the xi's.
OK.
So that's just for
the posterior one.
AUDIENCE: What's [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: This guy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 2a.
AUDIENCE: 2a.
Oh, OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Right.
So I get a plus a plus n.
And then those two guys cancel.
OK?
And that's what you have here.
So for a is equal to 1/2--
and I claim that this
is Jeffreys prior.
Because remember, Jeffreys was
[INAUDIBLE] was square root
and was proportional to
the square root of p1 minus
p, which I can write as p to
the 1/2, 1 minus p to the 1/2.
So it's just the case
a is equal to 1/2.
OK.
So if I use Jeffreys prior, I
just plug in a equals to 1/2,
and this is what I get.
OK?
So those things are going
to have an impact again when
n is moderately large.
For large n, those things,
whether you take Jeffreys prior
or you take whatever
a you prefer,
it's going to have
no impact whatsoever.
But n is of the
order of 10 maybe,
then you're going to
start to see some impact,
depending on what
a you want to pick.
OK.
And then in the second
example, well, here we actually
computed the posterior
to be this guy.
Well, here, I can just read off
what the expectation is, right?
I mean, I don't have
to actually compute
the expectation of a Gaussian.
It's just that xn bar.
And so in this case,
there's actually no--
I mean, when I have a
non-informative prior
for a Gaussian, then I
have basically xn in bar.
As you can see, actually, this
is an interesting example.
When I actually look
at the posterior,
it's not something that cost
me a lot to communicate to you,
right?
There's one symbol here, one
symbol here, and one symbol
here.
I tell you the posterior is
a Gaussian with mean xn bar
and variance 1/n.
When I actually turn
that into a poster mean,
I'm dropping all
this information.
I'm just giving you
the first parameter.
So you can see there's
actually much more information
in the posterior than there
is in the posterior mean.
The posterior mean
is just a point.
It's not telling me how
confident I am in this point.
And this thing is
actually very interesting.
OK.
So you can talk about
the posterior variance
that's associated to it, right?
You can talk about,
as an output,
you could give the posterior
mean and posterior variance.
And those things are
actually interesting.
All right.
So I think this is it.
So as I said, in general,
just like in this case,
the impact of the prior
is being washed away
as the sample size
goes to infinity.
Just well, like here, there's
no impact of the prior.
It was an noninvasive one.
But if you actually had an
informative one, [? CF ?]
homework-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
so [? CF ?] homework,
you would actually see an
impact of the prior, which,
again, would be washed away
as your sample size increases.
Here, it goes away.
You just get xn bar over 1.
And actually, in
these cases, you
see that the posterior
distribution converges
to-- sorry, the
Bayesian estimator
is asymptotically normal.
This is different from the
distribution of the posterior,
right?
This is just the posterior
mean, which happens
to be asymptotically normal.
But the posterior
may not have a--
I mean, here, the
posterior is a beta, right?
I mean, it's not normal.
OK, so there's
different-- those things
are two different things.
Your question?
AUDIENCE: What was
the prior [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: All 1, right?
That was the improper prior.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And so that would give you the
same thing as [INAUDIBLE],, not
just the proportion.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Well, I mean, yeah.
So it's essentially
telling you that--
so we said that, when you
have a non-informative prior,
essentially, the maximum
likelihood is the maximum
a posteriori, right?
But in this case,
there's so much symmetry,
that it just so happens that
the maximum in this thing
is completely symmetric
around its maximum.
So it means that the expectation
is equal to the maximum,
to [INAUDIBLE] max.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I read
somewhere that one
of the issues with
Bayesian methods
is that we choose
the wrong prior,
and it could mess
up your results.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, but hence,
do not pick the wrong prior.
I mean, of course, it would.
I mean, it would mess
up your res-- of course.
I mean, you're putting
extra information.
But you could say the
same thing by saying,
well, the issue with
frequentist method
is that, if you mess up the
choice of your likelihood,
then it's going to
mess up your output.
So here, you just have two
chances of messing it up,
right?
You have the-- well, it's gone.
So you have the product of
the likelihood and the prior,
and you have one
more chance to--
but it's true, if you
assume that the model is
right, then, of course,
finding the wrong prior could
completely mess up things
if your prior, for example,
has no support on
the true parameter.
But if your prior has a positive
weight on the true parameter
as n goes to infinity--
I mean, OK, I cannot speak
for all counterexamples
in the world.
But I'm sure, under minor
technical conditions,
you can guarantee
that your posterior
mean is going to
converge to what
you need it to converge to.
Any other question?
All right.
So I think this closes the more
traditional mathematical-- not
mathematical, but traditional
statistics part of this class.
And from here on, we'll
talk about more multivariate
statistics, starting with
principal component analysis.
So that's more like when
you have multiple data.
We started, in a way, to talk
about multivariate statistics
when we talked about
multivariate regression.
But we'll move on to
principal component analysis.
I'll talk a bit about
multiple testing.
I haven't made my
mind yet about what
we'll talk really in December.
But I want to make
sure that you have
a taste and a flavor of what is
being interesting in statistics
these days, especially as you
go towards more [INAUDIBLE]
learning type of questions,
where really, the focus is
on prediction rather
than the modeling itself.
We'll talk about
logistic regression,
as well, for example,
which is generalized
linear models, which is just
the generalization in the case
that y does not take value in
the whole real line, maybe 0,1,
for example, for regression.
All right.
Thanks.